ante miles de taiwaneses los bailarines
ofrecieron un espectáculo tradicional y
la guardia de honor militar marchó
Taiwán celebró su fiesta nacional pero
el ambiente estuvo lejos de ser festivo
en medio de nuevas tensiones con China
la presidenta
advirtió
el pueblo taiwanés y nuestros diversos
partidos políticos creen que debemos
defender nuestra soberanía nacional y
nuestro modo de vida libre y democrático
en este punto no dejamos espacio para el
compromiso los 24 millones de habitantes
de Taiwán viven bajo la constante
amenaza de Invasión por parte de China
Beijing considera La Isla como una
provincia Rebelde de la que tomará el
control tarde o temprano así sea por la
fuerza esta crisis se remonta la guerra
civil china en 1949 los nacionalistas se
retiraron a Taiwán tras su derrota ante
los comunistas se instaló
régimen que fue rápidamente defendido
por Estados Unidos este verano la visita
de Nancy pelosi presidenta de la cámara
de representantes de Estados Unidos
Crespo aún más las tensiones en
represalia China hizo volar misiles
sobre Taiwán en la ONU reiteró su
objetivo
la soberanía y la integridad territorial
de China nunca fueron rotas
china continental y Taiwán pertenecen a
una sola entidad esto nunca cambió
los chinos nunca hemos dejado de
esforzarnos por lograr la reunificación
a nivel internacional el estatus de
Taiwán sigue sin estar claro solo 14
países la reconocen oficialmente como
estado y no está representada en la ONU
sin embargo Taiwán Disfruta de un
sistema democrático y se ha desarrollado
económicamente la industria taiwanesa
llegó a ser imprescindible teniendo la
mayor producción mundial de
semiconductores